yo my free city bros who would have
known that these fan favorite scenes in
free guy weren't part of the script what
we fell in love with ryan reynolds smash
hit action comedy free guy and the
exciting world it created and a large
part of that is thanks to reynolds and
sean levy and i guess that means i play
guy reynolds has proven himself to have
a knack for improv in his films and once
again there was plenty of improvisation
incorporated on the set of free guy
spoilers for free guy are up ahead
blue shirt
yes
one of the comedic highlights of free
guy is when it's revealed that one of
the initial bank robbers in the game
happens to be a preteen girl and her
younger sister behind the keyboard the
scene was actually added after the film
had wrapped shooting and came from the
lovable snarky mind of ryan reynolds
reynolds pitched the idea to director
sean levy who then got his two daughters
to film the scene in their bedroom it
was a moment that certainly paid off
that man is dead he's so sleepy taika
ytt is a comedy force of nature and the
cast and crew got to experience even
more of tyka's charm here's the thing
when i said that
i was lying sean levy revealed that
there was hours of footage of ytt going
off on rants in character as the
villainous antoine of course working
with that much footage most of it went
onto the cutting room floor levy
absolutely loved having ytt's energy on
set the great thing about him is he's so
loose and he's so experimental that
he'll just try jokes knowing most of
them won't work but never being
embarrassed to try perhaps we'll get to
see some more of tyka's freestyle rant
in the special features why would i do
that when i can make a sequoia one of
the best lines in the movie comes in
antoine's rant about sticking to ip and
making sequels albuquerque boiled turkey
why would i make another restaurant
called i don't know albuquerque boiled
turkey this line was actually improvised
by taika ytt and the cast and crew loved
the phrase so much that it gave them
inspiration for the sequel both ryan
reynolds and sean levy agree that they
want the sequel if it were to happen to
be titled albuquerque boiled pick we
couldn't agree more
one of the most bittersweet moments in
free guy was the cameo appearance of the
late host of jeopardy alex trebek levy
revealed that trebek was added into the
film during post-production reynolds who
had previously contributed to the
beloved game show had simply called
trebek to see if he was interested in
filming a cameo which he happily
accepted
jeopardy here and there over the years
um and we asked him and he said yes
channing tatum's cameo was particularly
amusing in free guy but the payoff
reveal may have been even better the
reveal that the player behind tatum is
actually an acne laced 23 year old
freeloader living with his mother was
another scene that was not in the script
and that was added in post levy shot the
scene in an abandoned office on a
saturday afternoon using a red camera
the studio even asked levy if he wanted
to reshoot the scene but he declined
thinking it was perfect as is if it
ain't broke don't fix it while joe kiri
had a blast on set a free guy he always
had felt intimidated by taika ytt's
ability at improv kiri didn't have as
much experience at improv but was
certainly willing to give it a try i
don't think i'm an improv savant
necessarily but i can hold my own though
during one of the scenes he shot with
ytt he was able to make the comedian
laugh with one of his lines kiri felt
like he had made a personal victory and
it felt so good so we could make it
better free guy boasts several popular
streamer personalities such as
jacksepticeye ninja pokemon and dan tdm
who appeared throughout the film as
themselves the streamers were only given
a vague outline on what was happening in
the film and were told to act as
themselves what made the streamers even
more at ease was the fact that they were
able to film at home and gave them even
more opportunities to portray their
respected personalities on screen i've
never seen anything like this free guy
was filmed right around the time of the
fox disney merger which allowed sean
levy and ryan reynolds to add things
that weren't originally in the script
the star wars and marvel cameos during
the guy and dude showdown was one of
those last minute from the moment
inclusions levy and reynolds also wrote
a letter to disney asking if they could
use items from the iconic franchises and
the studio was happy to oblige
which led to one of the film's biggest
crowd-pleasing moments ryan reynolds
didn't just improvise as the titular
blue shirt-wearing hero but he also had
the chance to freestyle as guy's hulking
double dude while bodybuilder aaron w
reed served as the body double reynold's
face was digitally added to reeds in
post-production during the process
reynolds was able to perform improv and
play around as dude particularly in the
final showdown which he clearly had a
blast with
once sean levy and ryan reynolds were
given the okay to incorporate the marvel
and star wars pop-ups in the film they
had another brilliant idea in the span
of a day the two had an idea for a cameo
that would feature captain america
himself chris evans who just so happened
to also be filming a project in boston
reynolds called evans for a quick favor
and once he arrived it was all done
within 10 minutes the avengers have to
help each other out after all apparently
chris hemsworth wasn't camera ready at
least that is what evans told reynolds
the unabashed anthem of free guy is
clearly mariah carey's hit song fantasy
which not only was played in most of the
film's marketing but is played several
times throughout the movie including the
credits the song's inclusion wasn't
always planned in fact initially levy
and reynolds planned on using your love
by the outfield but didn't feel like it
was a natural fit instead reynolds
suggested to levy that they used the
mariah carey hit and the rest was
history to top that off that was
actually jody comer doing her own
singing for when her character belts out
the classic tune i really wish you
mentioned that
one of the biggest changes made to free
guy that wasn't in the original script
was the entire personality of ryan
reynolds title character in fact in the
script guy was portrayed as a much more
cynical character who was fed up with
his simultaneously mundane and chaotic
life instead of being the happy-go-lucky
personality we fell in love with it was
reynolds idea to make guy feel more
comfortable and lovable and somebody who
was satisfied with his life inside of
free city trolls exist
one of the biggest differences from
script to screen was the fact that dude
wasn't in the initial script instead it
was reynolds idea to include dude while
initially the film's ultimate showdown
would have been entirely between guy and
antoine honestly it feels like only
someone with a mind like reynolds could
come up with such a character
catchphrase free guy's ending where
millie aka molotov girl ends up with
keys was not part of the original script
in fact in the film's original ending
millie would have ended up with guy
which would have been a bit weird to say
the least it was after several rewrites
of the script overseen by sean levy and
ryan reynolds that it ended up being
reworked so that the ending was more
practical this decision definitely seems
like it was for the best while many
studio blockbusters don't rely too much
on improvisation free guy director sean
levy greatly encouraged it on set this
group was kind of similarly inspired
very encouraged to improvise but also
very conscious of okay here's the story
we're telling so i'll go off-road for a
bit but i know intuitively when to bring
it back and service the story it was
this kind of direction that helped make
free guy as irresistibly charming and
hilarious as it is no no okay i i want
to comply it's so refreshing to hear
what a joyous experience the cast of
free guy had on set look like i'm still
in the middle of the desert with nothing
on but a hula hoop and a pair of leather
moon boots according to comer she and
reynolds had actually even gone off
script during their audition
do you have a favorite moment in freeguy
you